for people that don't know if you don't
mind taking a minute giving everybody
your background and how the story came
about with hunter biden's laptop
well uh it was friday night about 10
minutes before closing and hunter came
in with three liquid damaged macbooks
and i can tell you for a fact that was
not one of them
that is a photo probably part of a
disinformation operation but we can go
into that later uh he he showed up one
was by the way just out of curiosity is
the actual laptop's picture anywhere
online no
so you never took a picture of it no you
don't have a video of the laptop no i
have the serial number but you didn't
take any videos or anything with the lap
i i wanted that thing out of my shop no
[ __ ] you know wow it was
number one priority was get it to the
authorities so i could have some level
of protection okay so go ahead i'm sorry
keep continuing so
uh he came in the 15-inch macbook pro
had a bo biden foundation sticker on it
so
i kind of instantly assumed because his
brother had passed away i believe about
a year before
that these were his deceased brothers
laptops because a lot of customers come
in and they want to recover their
memories off of their deceased loved
ones devices so it is a common thing and
i felt bad for the guy and even though i
was trying to get out of there i was
like look i didn't you know he's got
three macs i would normally charge 200 a
pop for data recovery let me see
the severity of the failure so i helped
them out one machine was a complete
write-off the other machine just had
missing or inoperable keys from liquid
damage so i gave him a keyboard and i
showed him how to that's how i learned
his password
uh so if there's any question on hacking
usually people that get hacked don't
voluntarily give away their passwords in
that process uh john paul you're in
delaware correct yep wilmington okay so
that's biden country so yeah i live
about 10 miles from okay and when he
walked in did you know exactly who he
was or guys i know you're visually
impaired
where does that come into the to play
here i didn't know who i was talking to
until
he
presented the beau biden thing and then
and when i was checking him in at the
actual check-in process i asked him who
he was and he was like hunter and then
obviously you just knew exactly who that
was right and there or what when he
sarcastically
said biden when i requested his last
name because i think he just
automatically anticipated me knowing who
he was
um
i i then i was like all right and then
the bow biden sticker kind of put
everything together but again i never
really cared what he looked like or who
he was for that matter and this is in
2019 this is april 12 2019. got it
so i uh i give him back the one machine
the third machine uh had some power
issues wouldn't power on so i had to
take it in the back and check that one
in so i ultimately just created a bill
that said data recovery for three max
because
again i hadn't gone through them yet
and 85 bucks which is the basically the
lowest rate that i could charge somebody
and because again at that time i thought
i was helping this guy who's inebriated
he looked a mess and i thought he was in
grieving this is
his deceased brothers things so
i didn't discover until i started doing
the data recovery the following day that
this was not his deceased brother's
laptops these were actually his
um and then i saw a lot of compromising
a lot of embarrassing material on the
laptop but again this was april 12th the
13th 14th 15th so this wasn't
his dad wasn't running for president yet
so and i never thought he would because
it was joe
he was kind of in in declining years so
uh
i really didn't get afraid until
about a couple weeks later when his
father announced his candidacy and i
realized that there's probably going to
be
a member on this staff or a secret
service member that's going to find this
piece of paperwork authorizing me to
recover data from these three laptops
and if they know what's on those laptops
then i'm the only one on the planet that
knows
about that behavior and
i i thought my days were numbered so i
needed to
uh when it became my property
in about mid-july up three years ago
i i knew that i needed to get it to the
authorities but i didn't trust local
authorities i didn't trust the fbi uh
roger stone was raided i think in
january that previous january so i had
definitely apprehensions about going to
the fbi so i went to the only person i
really trusted and that was my father
and in uh september of uh 2019 on a car
ride back from
uh
a gunship reunion in
utah it was like a seven hour drive back
to
denver
and mom's asleep in the back so i
figured this is a good time to to
explain to my situation and my father
and
and uh i told him everything and and not
everything he didn't want to know
certain things for plausible deniability
but we both agreed that the best thing
for him to do was give get him the
paperwork get him a copy of the drive so
he could approach the fbi out in
albuquerque
and about this time my mom woke up and
she made this statement she goes that
sounds like the laptop from hell so
needless to say she's pretty upset with
miranda devine for stealing the title
but
so on october 8th after i mailed my
father a copy of the drive and gave him
all the paperwork or copies of the
paperwork he went to the fbi
field office in albuquerque
where an agent refused to give his name
kind of harassed my father
questioned
motives questioned the legality of my
the possession of the device and
basically told him to lawyer up and get
out of the get out of the office wow
and i mean this is the first time my
father's career 31-year career colonel
in the air force
uh never asked anything
from
the you know the bureaucracy basically
and so he was a bit disappointed that
you know all he wanted was protection
for his son so
about a month later apparently it got
the attention of someone because the fbi
reached out to him in an effort to get a
hold of me
we agreed and the fbi came to my house i
explained the situation in about
beginning of november and yeah
about mid-november
and i presented them with some stuff i
had printed up because during this time
the impeachment hearings had started or
there was whispers of it it was getting
close there was now the big concern sure
i'm fearful of my safety i've definitely
witnessed criminal activity on this
device
uh but now there's an impeachment that's
whispers of impeachment that's occurring
over a phone call
about the previous administration in
ukraine and i had seen enough
information on that laptop to know that
there was a blatant pay-for-play scheme
the biden's made out like bandits during
the 2014 ukrainian uh conflict
and
in my opinion from what i had seen
president trump had every reason to
call zielinski considering zielinski was
created by igor kolomoisky
who was hunted by his business partner
and when when the bidens could no longer
protect kolomoisky and his billions that
he embezzled during the ukraine conflict
uh
kolomoisky did the next best thing he
made his own president he took his prize
actor from his tv
series and or tv station and groomed him
to be the president got him elected so
now he doesn't have to worry first thing
zelinski did when he got elected was uh
the the privatization
of
uh prof the bank which was igor's bank
he made that illegal so igor could have
his bank back have his money back and
return to the country so it was
to and to watch what's happening in
ukraine happen all over again it's it's
scary except this time we're sending
40 billion instead of 18 billion uh john
what would you say if i mean if you can
even say it besides the you know the
ukraine and all that type of stuff what
was the most disturbing thing that you
saw that you i don't know if you told
anybody but what was there anything that
would make you go like oh my god like he
should be in prison for this 100
um
yeah
i i think i know where you're getting
that yeah
and and there has been a lot of efforts
by a lot of individuals out there to
metaphorically
or
not literally insert
fake data onto this laptop and there's a
couple reasons why somebody would want
to do this they either want to get
notoriety and fame for something that
they have zero involvement in
or
there's an effort to insert questionable
material into a laptop that's in the
possession of members of congress so if
you wanted to
punish certain members of congress then
you have an excuse to say especially if
they received into copies of a drive
that has this alleged material from an
individual that may have put this in
material on it and the other concern
that we should be careful like hunter
signed a document after 90 days that
laptop became my property
if there's another laptop out there that
has 450 gigs of mysteriously discovered
80 000 images of this or whatever
that came from something else
that was not legally acquired so if you
start to muddy the waters and then we're
expected to have something that's going
to be admitted as evidence and and
hopefully trials that'll occur in the
next couple years we can't have that
information be tainted
and we can't have somebody throw it all
out because somebody decided to run an
operation to
lie about the contents of the data so we
have to be really careful i didn't see
any cp in the levels that people were
talking
i saw a lot of inappropriate behavior
with family members
and and that's all i'm going to talk
about wow
inappropriate behavior with family
members
okay let me speculate let me i'm going
to speculate you know
you can decide to say whatever you want
to say
speculative
inappropriate content with family
members
so
it would be drugs it would be sex it
would be theft
it would be
accounts it would be what else it would
be i mean that's what it's going to be
outside of that what else would be in
there right
again like i've always told people
there's enough criminal material on that
laptop we don't need to make up anything
we don't need to
find a dark place in our minds where we
want to believe that there's this evil
that's on it that's there's enough evil
on it we don't need to make up who has
the laptops now
well the fbi should they took it from me
gave me a subpoena and everything and a
receipt and
that was december 9th 2019. uh if
they've lost it i i have a cop i still
have the copy that i gave my father
which predates the copy i gave to rudy
or rudy's office because i i never gave
it to rudy did you sign off that you can
never talk about what's in the laptop
did you say that to the fbi or no the
only thing i remotely said to the fbi
like that was jokingly uh when they were
leaving
i said don't worry lads when i write the
book i'll leave your names out
and that's when one agent turned around
and said
in our experience nothing ever happens
to people that don't talk about these
things
so you so you and i was like all right
i'm going to be quiet so you've never
told anything to anybody about the
laptop
well not until i reached out directly to
uh rudy giuliani's office i so
when the fbi took possession of
everything my fingers were crossed
because i was hoping even though a lot
of red flags occurred they told me that
if anybody or hunter came looking for it
i was to
give him a bs story that it's off-site
and give me a couple days to get it i
was immediately to text agent mike and
he would
return the laptop to me so i'm thinking
if this is evidence how can they return
it and that's kind of
where i started to feel like they cared
more about the owner of the previous
owner of the laptop and protecting them
than they did about protecting me so
and of course when the impeachment
happened and this laptop was nowhere to
be seen and it wasn't admitted as
evidence for the defense from the white
house then i was just like
okay we need to go to
another level here so i sent my father
and my uncle who's also a retired
colonel in the air force to i gave them
enough material basically the material i
had printed up and given to the tried to
give to the fbi but they didn't touch it
they just gave me a subpoena wanted all
his stuff and then left
so they went out knocked on members of
congress
their doors to get their attention alert
them uh i even believe my uncle ron sent
the fax to the white house directly
saying we have national concern national
security concerns because not only for a
pay for play but just the amount of
sensitive data that was being sent
in the open unencrypted to private
ukrainian citizens and this information
included everything from the vice
president's travel schedule
all policies and procedures economics
any discussion that the white house
would have relating to ukraine was being
sent to a private ukrainian citizen that
worked for a company that was employing
the vice president's son
and that is not cool so john paul you it
sounds like not only were you fixing the
laptop you were getting in there i mean
you were looking at there were and this
isn't i don't think
hearsay there was pornography on there
there's a lot okay boom there's
definitely some smoke and crack stuff
going on a lot boom
um but then there's this ukrainian
business dealing stuff
sounds like you went pretty deep into
those
emails yeah absolutely when when it
became my property and i'm thinking
somebody's going to kick down my door
i'm i'm waiting for it to happen i'm
trying desperately i called him up
multiple times through the month of
april and may
to to come and pick up this you called
hunter you're saying
no answers no messages no nothing no
text zero response didn't come back i
sent them automated square payment
request so he was you know here's 80 you
owe the max 85 bucks ding well there was
no response whatsoever well he responded
the so when i called him up i want to
say it was like the 15th yeah when i was
done with the recovery was like the
following monday call them up to let
them know hey you know i recovered about
220 gigabytes of data
go to best buy if you get a drive that's
you know 500 gigs or bigger that'll be
more than enough uh drop it off give me
24 hours and then i'll i'll knock it out
so he shows up on the 16th and drops off
the drive so i know he's getting my
messages i know he's so he did come back
to them
and dropped off a dropped off hard drive
a two terabyte western digital uh
external drive okay so you know if he
has any doubt where where he was
on that weekend i can say that he was at
a best buy and his credit card
but then he never came back to pick up
yeah that's when he asked me to bill him
electronically i said is square okay
he's like sure and then he never came
back in
so you've got multiple dealings with
hunter biden the first time that he
showed up first time and then the second
time when he came to drop off the the
drive and then after he dropped off the
drive zero response after that zero
except until his lawyer
called me up on october 13th 2020 the
day before the uh
new york post ran the story so the eve
of that uh he called me up because i
guess it's common practice for
when your story is going to go you want
to reach out to those involved
see if they have a statement so he calls
me up about 10 minutes before closing on
that tuesday
and it was like yeah my client left a
laptop with you he said 2017 so i was
like oh
hunter doesn't remember
2019 but i'll go with it so i kind of i
did what the fbi told me to do i said
hey
normally we don't hold on to equipment
that long but i'll check in our
reclamation center tomorrow and can you
shoot me an email with your credentials
and and so i know that you can represent
officially represent the client and he
agreed so i have an email saying hey i'm
hunter's lawyer thanks for talking to me
tonight so i was like well that's good
enough for me and then i
immediately called bob costello who was
my point of contact at rudy giuliani's
office
and i'm and he was also
promised me that if anything ever hit
the fan i was to call him and he'd take
care of my security needs so i call him
up and i'm like i think it hit the fan i
just got a call from uh george masaras
who's hunter's lawyer and he's like ah
that ship sailed
go go home get some sleep
nothing can be done it's uh the story's
coming out tomorrow and i'm like okay
great
the fact that um george maseras asked me
on the phone he said are you still at
the back side of trolley square
and that was like enough for me not to
go home that night because i figured he
knew he knew exactly where i was
so and the story hadn't broken yet i
figured once the story was out
then i would be okay because then i
wouldn't be
murdered so
unfortunately watching the next day
watching the
the internet and mainstream media put a
kibosh on on the whole story and prevent
the truth from getting out and then the
narrative is being replaced that i
you know colluded with a foreign power
to effect an election
so that uh
things started to go downhill rather
quickly after that so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
you